- [Instructor] So
something very interesting
is clearly going on when
we look at this pencil
dipped in this cup of water.
We would expect if maybe there
was no water in this glass
that we would just see the
pencil continue straight down
in a line that looks something like that.
But that's clearly not what we are seeing.
It looks like, once we fill it with water,
at least to our eye,
it looks like the pencil
gets bent or broken
or bent in some way.
And this notion,
you might have heard
people call it refraction.
But it's interesting
thing about exactly why
this is happening.
And I'll give you a hint.
This is all about the bending of light.
And it's not just light that can get bent
as it goes from one medium into another.
It can be any kind of wave.
So let's think about
what's going on over here.
So first, let's think about
the part of the pencil
that is above the water.
So this part right over here,
the light is actually
reflecting off of this pencil,
and then it's bouncing
straight into our eye.
So just imagine a path from this dot
straight into your eye.
Once again, from here, it's
going straight into your eye.
When we go over here, it still
doesn't look too distorted.
So you have light that's
going straight to your eye.
It's going through the side of the glass
and then getting to your eye.
But then once we get under the water,
something's interesting.
You would expect the point
that would have been here
would then go straight to your eye
just like everything up here.
But it turns out that that light,
once it transitions from going
from the water to the glass
and then the air, it bends.
So at the interface between the media,
between those different materials
that the light is traveling through,
instead of going towards your eye,
it gets bent, in this case to our left.
And so that's why when
we look straight on here,
we don't see anything in
this region right over here.
But the light that was going
from the pencil towards
this part of the glass,
which typically you would not see,
that would have typically
just gone straight
in that direction and not hit your eye,
well, now that is getting refracted.
It's getting bent to the left
so that now that light hits your eye.
So that's why you see what
looks like a broken pencil.
It's all about the light getting bent
as it exits the water
and goes into the glass
and then the air.